[Music]
hi
so you've done all your preparation and
practiced your english a lot and now you
want to know what you can do during the
exam here are five tips to help you get
the best mark in your next speaking exam
number one remember
it's not a race so slow down before you
speak think carefully about what you
want to say and speak a little slower
than normal
number two
if you don't understand the question or
the activity don't worry ask the
examiner to explain it again
you can say something like could you
repeat that please
number three
when you're asked a question don't just
say yes or no as your answer the
examiner wants to know how good your
english is so try to explain your answer
with a reason say yes i agree because or
no i don't think so because
number four
look at the examiners or other students
faces and eyes when you speak
faces can tell you a lot if you see that
the examiner or your partner don't
understand you then say it again using
different words
and finally number five
speak clearly so that the examiner can
hear you if you find this difficult
practice with a friend at home stand at
opposite ends of a room and speak to
each other in english or speak to each
other in english online or on the phone
okay so these are our top five tips but
just one final piece of advice your
teacher or examiner are only human and
usually they will really want you to do
well so
take a deep breath
smile
relax
and good luck on your next speaking exam
[Music]
for more tips on learning english why
not subscribe to our channel and visit
the learn english teens website for more
learning material
[Music]